よろしくお願いします
今日は何番目？ 3番から 4
番  ウッターナワト サティマト スチカン マッサニサンマカーリノ サンニャタッサチャダンマジーヴィノ アッパマタッサヤソービワンダティ
ウッターナワト サティマト スチカン マッサニサンマカーリノ サンニャタッサチャダンマジーヴィノ アッパマタッサヤソービワンダティ
というのは この24番目の偈なんです
大体この法句経のテキストを勉強する場合は
この偈一つ一つ独立しているんです
ですから この一個の偈を勉強してみても
お釈迦様がおっしゃりたがっていることは理解できるだろうとは思います
それから このまず言葉の意味を見てみましょう 1
番目の言葉はウッターナワト
ウッターナというのは立ち上がるという意味なんですね
起きるという意味なんですね
ワトといえばワンタという
そういう性格を持っているということで
だから日本語でどういう言葉でいいかどうかちょっとわかりませんだけど
一応まずこの事象の意味でね
見てみて ウッターナというのは立ち上がること
その性格を持っている
2番目はサティマトですね
サティっていうのは このヴィパッサナー瞑想でやっているサティのことで気づくことですね
いわゆる現在の状況に気づくということなんですね
今に気づく 過去に気づいたっても
あ しまったなということで終わりますけど
やっぱり今に気づくと
そういうことになりませんね
で それで  2行目でスチという言葉がございます
スチっていうのは この清らかなっていうね
汚れてないという意味で
カンマっていうのは行為ですね
清らかな行為 汚れてない行為
それからスチカンマっていうのは
ですから汚れてない行為っていうことは善行為でもあるし
良い行為でも 良い行為ですね
悪い行為はと反対で スチカンマのニサンマカーリの
ニサンマカーリっていうのはちょっと訳はややこしいんですけど
ニサンマカーリっていうのはまあ
まあ一応伸ばしてみよう言うなれば
まあこういう風にすればこういう結果になるんだよと
この行為はこういう風に調整すれば
まあこういう風な結果になりますよと
ただ単にこうやってやっちゃうといい結果が出てこないよと
まあそういうふうにこのよくよく理解してやることをやるんですね
例えば我々はただ何かやっただけで良い結果が出てこない場合もありますね
あるいは良いことはしたんだけど
結果が悪かったということもありますね
それでものすごい苦労して良い行為したんですけど
結果があまりにも小さすぎということもあります
そういうどちらでもあまりいいことじゃないんですね
だから自分がやってることは明確にスタディしてないんですね
だから何をやるにしたっても
やっぱりちょっとここら辺は研究して
どのようにやればよろしいかというところらへんの研究的な
この調べてみる判断能力というようなあるんですね
ただ やみくもにやるということじゃないんです
よく理解して状況を把握して
結果をちゃんと配慮して
まあ他の言葉で言えば
まあ少々の努力で短い時間で大きな結果を出せるようにと
かなりいろいろ工夫を練ってやることなんて
ニサンマカーリっていうのはそういうやり方なんです
ただ清らかな行為しなさいよっていう意味じゃないんです
ただ 清らかな行為であろうとも
やみくもにやってもね
もう何のこともないんですよ
で まあそういう意味 だから短い日本語でどういう言葉でよろしいか
ちょっとどういう言葉でいいんでしょうかね
ニサンマカーリ  よく考慮して
考慮する  考えに気を配る
気を配ってやるとか まあまあいくらかはそんな感じなんですけど
やっぱりもうちょっとただね
もう一つという気持ちはあるんですね
木曜日の時にあの 木曜日の時にですね
長老がお話しになった時は
そのことが能力があるっていう時にご説明になりましたよね
まあちょっと  だから能力ある人のやり方なんです
一応二三枚変わりっていうのは能力ない人がもうやむくもにやりますから
結果どうなるかっていうのは誰もわからないんですね
でも能力ある人がやると結果は決まってます
良い結果出ますよと 巧みにと
巧みにいいかもね じゃあそういう風にしましょう
良い行為を巧みにこなす
行う そこで 3行目 サンニャタッスという言葉がございます
サンニャタッス サンニャタっていうのというのは元の言葉ですね
サンニャタ サンニャタっていうのは落ち着いているということなんです
しかしまだ意味があるんですよ
それで終わるわけじゃないんです
この我々は 見たり 喋ったり
聞いたり 体を動かしたりする行為をするんですね
だいたい主にこの体と口の行為のことなんですね
見る聞くことも入りますけどね
そういうところで落ち着いている
焦ってはいけないというね
何をするにも落ち着いて行なう
焦ることはしない だらしないようには全く何もしない
ということで だから服を着る着る時でも
着替える時でも 歩く時でも
座る時でも 食べる時でも
人と話す時でも かなり落ち着いてかなり落ち着いて焦ることをしないで行うことがこのサンニャタということなんですね
だから 短いわかりやすい日本語で言うならば
焦らないことって書いてあってもいいんです
しかし 仏教専門的な定義はまた別にございまして
その場合は定義は結局在家の定義なんですけど
出家の定義なんですけど
出家の場合はね 皆様にはその場合は関係ないと言われてしまうかもしれませんだけど
出家の場合は見ること
聞くこと 嗅ぐこと 味わうこと
それから歩いたり座ったり食べたりする
そういう行為 寝たり起きたり
それらの行為をすべて落ち着いてやる
どのように落ち着くかというと
落ち着きの定義もあります
心に怒りやら欲やら混乱やら
そういうものは起こらないようにと気を配ること
だから何か見てもいいんだけど
見て見ても心は混乱しないように
心に欲がもういきなり発生しないように
怒りがもう爆発しないようにと
常に心の中の平安な状態を守ってやろう
守ってやろうということにすごく気を配るんです
そこがサンニャタのこの完全な定義なんです
だからなぜ出家の定義かというと
まあそこまで在家の人々にはね
まあかなり難しいというかね
無理なところもありますので
まあ悪いことをしないで
焦らないで頑張ってくださいということで十分やと思いますね
まあ例えば在家の人々は家族がいる場合はね
まあやっぱり自分の子供を見ると
まあ愛情がどうしても生まれてくるし
子供がなんかもういたずらしたり
いい加減なことをやったりしちゃうと
まあすぐ怒ってしつけしてしまうということもあるしね
で まあそこら辺でいろいろ感情がね
入り込んでトラブルを起こしたりするのはありまして
いいわけじゃないんだけど
そう簡単に管理はできないかもしれませんね
でも出家の場合は結構厳密にやらなくちゃいけない
たとえ弟子をしつけしたり
怒ったり怒鳴ったりしても
心の中は怒ってはいけないんですね
心の中はずっと落ち着いて保たなくちゃ
落ち着きが落ち着きを保たなくちゃいけないんですね
結構厳しい修行になります
それがサンニャタという言葉の意味ね
落ち着くこと あるいは焦らないこと
それで次の言葉はダンマジーヴィの
まあダンマジーヴィというのは生活のことで生きてることのダンマによって生きている
ダンマっていうのは法であって真理であって正しいことなんですね
いわゆる正しく生き方をする
そうすると前の言葉とダブっちゃうんじゃないんでしょうかね
スチカンマスタというのは清らかな行為をするということで
ダブルナインです こちらで言ってるのは生きることなんです
このダンマジービっていうのは
どんな生き方をするんでしょうかと
我々はどういうふうに生きていればよろしいかといえば
ダンマによって 真理によって
真理を犯す 事実をねじ曲げることをしないで生活をする
その場合は清らかな行為をするということは
その中にまた入ってしまいますけど
一応 2つなんですね で
生き方 それがこの 特に仏教はこの
分けてみるんです 何でも生き方にはしないんです
例えば どんな人でも喋る
喋ることはその人の生き方ではないんです
生きてるんだから喋ってるだけなんです
しかし まあ弁護士か教師か
そういう仕事をする それで教師はその人の生活
生き方なんです 生き方っていうのは
この まあそういう意味の生き方
だからどんなものをして生活しているかって
いわゆる職業のことなんです
だから職業の場合は教師だから喋らなくちゃいけない
だから喋ることの 2つあります
1つは ただ普通生きてるんだから喋ることと
生活に関係があって喋ることと
歩くことの 2つあります
ただ 家の中に歩いたり
ちょっと散歩したり いろいろ歩くも歩きもあります
しかし 仕事のために歩く場合もあります
だから歩くことの意味がいつでも 2つなんです
そうやって我々はやってることっていうのは
あの生活のためにやることと
ただ生きてるんだからやることという 2つです
そこでこの生きてるんだから
まあまあ遊びでやってもやらなくても
だから 1つはやってもやらなくてもいいんですよ
例えば休みの日で家にいる
まあ散歩してきてもしてもしなくても
別にどちらでもいいんです
しかし 自分が新聞配達とか
もう何かもう牛乳配達をなんとか
あのバイトやってる 仕事している
その場合は歩き 歩いても歩けなくてもいいんだよって話じゃないでしょうに
その場合は必ずも歩かなくてはいけないんです
仕事だから だから歩くと言っても 2つあります
喋るといっても 2つあります
喋っても喋らなくてもどうでもいいことも
日常生活の中ではいいんですよ
しかし 教師で 私は今日喋りませんよと
そんな話は成り立ちませんね
教師だったらもう講義中は喋らなくてはいけないんですね
これ必ずもやらなくてはいけない行為がダンマジービの方に入れているんです
[終始背景音楽]そういうことで
あの 話す 歩く 見る 座る
何でも行為は何でもいいんだけど
2種類  2種類が出てくる
わがまま言うところじゃなくて
必ずもやらなくちゃいけないことと
まあ自分でやるかやらないかと自由に決めることと 2つあります
それでわがままは言えない
とにかくやらなくちゃいけない場合は
生活ということに入っちゃうんです
その人の生活はかかっている
まあ好き勝手にやってもやらなくてもいいやという場合は
生活はかかってないんです
例えば隣の奥さんとお話しするべきかないかということはね
それは別に生活がかかっているわけじゃなくて
ないんだからやってもやらなくてもいいんです
しかし 自分が訪問販売しているんだと
隣の家にも売らなくちゃいけないと言ったら
喋らなくちゃいけないんですね
その場合は自分の生活はかかっている
その時 我が身 あの人とあまり喋りたくないとかね
そういう我が儘は通らないんです
仕事ですから それでダンマジービっていうのは
この仕事の場合は 生活はかかっている場合は
真理に従って 事実に乗っ取って
ねじ曲がることを何もしないで
悪いことを何もしないでやりなさいということなんです
だから たとえ生活でかかってますよと仕事だよと言っても
仏教は悪いことは認めません
どんな言い訳をしても
悪いことには悪い結果が来る
法則をねじ曲がることはできません
私たちには法則に対して何の力もないんです
だからいい加減愚かな人間が法則をねじ曲げようと思っているんですが
全然うまくいくはずがないんです
悪いことをしても幸せになるんだと
みんなに褒めてくれるんだと
社会は認めてくれるんだと
そうはうまくいくはずがないんです
社会騙しても法則だから
自分の心を騙せないんですよ
だから業っていうのは自分の心ですからね
悪いことをすると 自分の心はもう変に回転する
自己破壊の方向へ 不幸になる方向へ
それやめられる？やめられません
例えば 自分が車のギアをRに入れたならば
前に進むというわけはないでしょうに
車のギアをRに入れちゃうと車は後ろに行くんです
だから この自分のやっている行為によって
心のギアは何に入れるかということなんです
前に進むようにDに入れるかRに入れるかっていうことを自分で決めなくちゃいけない
ただエンジンかけてもう車は回転したんだからといってね
後ろに行くか前に進むかっていうことは
その場でその場で決めなく
まあ車の場合はどちらでも必要ですけど
人生の場合は退化することは認められることはできんだからね
人は不幸になることはいいことですよとかね
それはちょっと人はだらしないようになることはいいことだということを
いかなる場合でも もうそういうケースはないんですね
だからこれはちょっと成り立たない
人生の場合は前に進まなくちゃいけないんです
進歩しなくてはいけないんです
それで進歩しないことは
仏教は罪 悪行為として見るんです
とにかくもう人生っていうのは全くも自由はないんですよ
好き勝手でわがままで全然生きていられません
なぜかというと この法則というものがあるんだから
因果法則というもの これはどうにもならん
人間に何の管理もできない
人間にできるのは この法則の中でどう生きるべきかという
法則をどう生かすかということであって
法則を管理するということじゃないんです
そういうわけで この悪いことにはいいわけはないんです
仏教ではいいわけないという話じゃないんですよ
もういいわけはないんです
無知な人は言い訳をするんだけど
何の意味もないんです
言い訳すると さらにその人は悪いことをしているんです
それでお釈迦様はそれをわかっているんだから
お釈迦様が言うのは 悪いことをするよりも言い訳することが悪いんだと
罪がすごく重いんです
で 悪いことはもうまあそっちゅう人間やってしまいますけど
それに言い訳つけちゃうと
もう極悪人で もう治る見込みはない
言い訳しないでそれを認める人が
その認めたことで良いことをしているんですよ
だから罪を認めたことで
その認めたこと自体が良いことだから
かなりそれであのマイナス点にプラスが入っちゃうんですよ
プラスが入るんだから
罪の重さが結構軽くなるんです
同じ例えば悪いことをします
一人がやっぱりそれを認めて
自分が悪かったと これからしないように頑張りますとかね
それ認めた時点でかなりプラス点が入ってますから
それで重さが低くなる
同じ悪いことした人がしょうがないんではないかと
そんなことはこの世の中で誰でもやってるんではないかと言っちゃうと
その人はあの行ったマイナス点よりももっと大きいマイナス点をもらっているんです
そうするとマイナスポイントも足しますからね
それでかなりの罪になっているんです
そういうわけで このただ単にみんな遊びで喋ったり歩いたりする時でも
悪いことはしてはいけないし
それで止まります しかし
生活の場合も たとえ生活がかかっていても
真理にのっとって生きていなくちゃいけないんだと
人間に 生命に個人で威張ることは全くできない
そういうことで これをダブっているわけじゃないんです
よく理解してほしいんだから
かなり知恵の教えなんです
だから ただいいことをしなさいというだけで済むはずがなんですけど
やっぱりそのその芸によって
それは明確に分けているんです
だから お釈迦様のたった一つの芸見ても
どれほどで どれほど知恵を使って語っているかとわかるし
それを理解する我々にしたっても
もう自分の人生がわかるでしょうに
喋るといったってもつあるんだ
私の場合でつあります
今は喋らなくてはいけない
でも これ終わってからは別に喋っても喋らなくてもどうでもいいんです
その場合は だから結構みんなあれやこれやと言うんだけど
私はほとんど喋れません
でも説法になってくるともう結構喋れます
日常生活の中で もう極力減らすんで喋ることは
喋らなくてもいい場合は全然喋りません
だからそれはそこの時点では自由ですけど
今の時点では自由ではなくて
どうしても喋らなくちゃいけない
だから同じ喋るということにしたっても種類ありますし
すべての行為にしたっても種類あります
見るということにはいつでも種類あります
聞くということにも種類があります
はい そういうことで 生活に関わるものにしたってもダンマジーリ法によって法にのって従って生活をしなくてはいけない
次にアッパマッタッサヤソービワッダティ
アッパマット アッパマットっていうのはまあよく使っている言葉は不放逸ですね
放逸しない人不放逸の人にという意味なんですけど
これで不放逸って何なのかというと
今まで説明したものなんです
それをまとめて一つの単語でアッパマット不放逸不放逸というんです
だから不放逸って何なのかとか困らなくてもいいんです
例えばウッターナワト
よく立ち上がる性格でサティーマト常に気づいている現状に
スチカンマ 悪いことはしない
それも悪いことしないではなくて
良いことを巧みにする
それから落ち着いている
心が汚れないように 混乱しないように落ち着いている
それから生活はきちんと真理にのっとってやっている
それが不放逸な生き方なんです
そういう不放逸な人のヤソービワッダティ
ヤサっていうのは 何でしょうかね
ヤサっていうのは栄光みたいな
光栄？栄光？どちらですかね
名声っていう名声 評判とか
聖書でもよく使うこの言葉
これは日本語になると栄光
光栄 なんとかっていう言葉に glory という言葉はね
栄光だな 神の栄光のために私が決まったとかなんとかってありますからね
例えば評判はあまりにも弱すぎ
それは他人任せですから評判ではないんです
これは独自立しているんです
栄光は 栄誉でもいいんですけど
私もこれ名声とか日本語の訳書いてあるんですけど
それは自分じゃなくて人から言われたような感じの訳ですから
それはちょっとなと思って
だから輝く人っていうふうにしたんですけど
輝くというか 自分から輝く人になろうっていうふうに
それ輝くはそれほど悪くないんです
まあちょっとそれは文学っぽいですけど
まあ輝きとかね だから英語のGLORYも似ているんです
輝きに で 神のGLORY GLORY
です すすりは で 聖書ではGLORYという言葉にはかかっているんです
例えばイエススがなぜ自分が来たんですか？と I
came here to glorify my father.と言うんですね
自分の父親をgloryfyというのはgloryの動詞ですね
そのために来たんだよと
だから神の父の栄光のために来ましたよという意味なんですね
そのgloryという言葉はこちらで
ヤサっていうのは英訳すればgloryでいいんです
だから輝きでもよろしいし
誉れっていう  誉れ？え？ 誉れっていうのがあって
名誉っていう意味  誉れね
名誉っていうんじゃなくて
誉れっていうのは自分でこう
何て言うんでしょう 自分がこうしっかり
むしろ誉れとかって言って
自分でこう情けないことせんっていうような
立派にやるんだっていう誉れ
そういうのと言われて評価される時点で
自分がむしろ誉れっていうのが一番よく使われる誉れ
私はまだ知らない単語だからね
そこはね どうかちょっと言いにくいんですけど
それからこのgloryというやつはね
栄光というものが単なるこの感情的で架空的なものというわけじゃないんです
例えば褒めてもらったとかね
評判というのはもう別にあってもなくてもどうでもいいんじゃないかということでも言えますけど
これはもっと具体的な中身があるんです
ヤサといえばね ということは
どうしても必要なものなんです
観念的なことでも ただ架空的なものでもない
評判がいいだけではもう
それでもご飯食べられないんだったらね
まあ意味がないしね あの人の仕事は随分もう評価されてますよと
しかし一人も買わないんだよと言っちゃうと
もうそれは glory じゃないんですね
例えば何か作品を作ったとしますね
それはもうすごく評価されて
その上すごい高いお金でもう買われてしまうという
だからその人にはものすごくお金も入るわ
それで終わることじゃなくて
ものすごく社会で認めて褒めてもらって
もう評判が良くて人気があってとか
何でも揃っている だから中身があるんです
易さといえば だからエゴの glory でも大体ね
中身があるんです 例えばキリスト教の言葉借りますけど
神を讃嘆しなさいと Praise
your father Praise
the god とかいろいろ言ってるんですね
神様偉いぞ偉いぞって言っても
glory にはならないんですよ
神様に 人間が人間が一斉に神様は偉大なりすごいすごいそうそうと言ったってもね
神様にとってはどうったことはないんですね
だからそれは本当にやったのはジェズス様やと
いわゆる神の王国を確定する
その王国を増やす それはジェズス様でなきゃできませんと
だから本当に神を glorify するのはジェズス様なんです
その人が人間に あんた方もこの天にいる父を褒めなさいと褒め称えなさいとは言っている
褒め称えただけで別になんのこともないんです
うるさいだけかもしれませんし
それでキリスト教だったらいろんなことを教えてるんですね
もうちゃんと懺悔することやら
洗礼を受けることやら
宗派によって変わりますけど
あの いろんな呪戒を守ることやらとか
そういうことをいっぱいやってると
本当に神の glory になるんですね
中身がある そういう人々はもう最後の審判で天国に天国
天国に行くように判断されて
そこで神の王国がかなり反映しているということで
それが glory というんです
だから名誉と言っても名誉というわけでもないし
評判といっても評判 ただ評判だけでもないし
うーん だから全部まとめないと
名誉 評判 栄光 それから幸福
全部まとめて使う言葉なんです
易っていうのは 全部入っている
というわけで じゃあ適切な日本語の単語
易っていうのは日本語辞書でどんな感じですかね
名誉とか名声とか  易 名声
名声 声誉かな 名声 名声にはしていますけどね
勲章  勲章っていうのは何ですか
お金？それ勲章ですか？日本語で
お金は名誉でしょ 勲章っていうのは英語ではメダルでしょう
メダルというタイトルとも言うしね
勲章みたいな 例えばもうそこら辺からもらうもんでしょ
知名度っていう  知名度でもないね
まあ例で言えばね 例えば日本のナショナル会社の社長とかね
設立した人々とかね で
決して誰も悪いことは言わないでしょ
立派な人だと世界的に知られてるでしょ
それですごい財産も富もあるでしょ
それから人格やら生き方やらって
もう人生哲学やらすごいすごいこと持ってるでしょ
揃ってるんです それがヤサなんです
知名度だけではないんで
知名度もある 名利 名誉
例えばこのパナソニックナショナル会社の設立社長なんかだったら
どんな言葉使ったらいいんですかね
松下幸之助ですか  松下幸之助しか言えないんだけど
松下幸之助は経営の神様
だから だから glory なんで
経営の神様と言った途端
それ glory なんですよ
富貴 中国の言葉で富貴といって
富と貴族の貴で 社会的な
つまり財産と社会的な地位
富と貴族の貴です 富貴
それで近いかもしれない
それがもしかすると近いかもね
富貴 まあ今まで出た言葉の中でもしかするとね
それが近いかも  名実ともに
名実 漢字は？ 名前の前に実るって書いて
ああ ああ これも それも悪くないんですね
名実も悪くないね 一応分かりますかね
この これ訳するのはどれほど難しいかと
[笑い]はい では まあ一応あの
何でしたっけ？不帰か明術かね
まあそちらはいくらか近いということで
だからその人の明術か不帰というものが
あの どんどんアビバルディっていうのは
まあ増えて増えていきますよと
増していきますよと どんどん成長して向上していきますよと
えーまあ一応私は一つの
一つの一番大事な言葉は説明しなかったんですね
一番最初の言葉 ウッターナワと
あの立ち上がる 怒るという性格といっても
それでは意味がちょっとわからないんですよ
で これはどういう意味かというと
この我々本来は怠けなんですよ
本来はもう堕落するようになってます
ですから 何かいいことをしようと思っちゃうと
やっぱり立ち上がらないとね
腰を上げないと まあ自然の流れでなんとなくっていうことは絶対できません
ただ 自然に頭が良くなったとか
自然に金持ちになったとか
そういうのはありえないんです
何にしたっても 我々はやっぱり行動を起こさなくちゃいけないんですよ
行動を起こすためには
自分の怠けと戦わなくちゃいけないんですね
いつでもどっさりとどこかで座って
まあボケ―としていたく
いたいという気持ちがずっとあるんです
だから ずっと我々は人生の中で
この起き上がる 立ち上がる
もうかかっていくという性格はスーッと必要なんです
やろうではないかという気持ち
善行為をしようと思う衝動に駆られる
心から立ち上がって そういう衝動に駆られて
だから衝動なんです 衝動っていうのは自然に出てこないんです
起こさないと  自発的に起こさなければいけない
衝動はいつも結構チャレンジ
あ？ チャレンジってことですか？ まあチャレンジですけど
まあやっぱりもっと専門的なね
仏教ではウッターナというね
やっぱり これは仏教専門用語でよく使ってる言葉なんですね
発心すると言いますか
発心ですね まあ発心ということは別な単語でも使いますけど
まあこの場合では発心ということなんです
で 発心というのはちょっとやばいところもありますけど
これ大乗仏教で使ってますから
一回発心すればそれで全部終わりますというね
そういう大乗仏教の教理学的な意味そのままでは使えないんですね
発心というのは いつでも発心しなくちゃいけない
大乗仏教になってくると
発心したらそれで菩薩ですから
もうOKなんですよ それはチットッパ―ダという別な専門用語なんです
チットッパ―ダ ボーディチットッパ―ダとかね
そういうのパーリ語でもありますけど
チットッパ―ダという言葉はないわけないんです
だから日本語で同じ言葉使ったっても
仏教の中からは言葉違うんです
ウッターナという言葉も大乗経典にもあるとは思いますけど
別な言葉だと思いますね
発心はチットッパ―ダという言葉なんですね
やっぱり  菩提心ということですか
いわゆる心を起こすんですね
決めることですね 何か決断する
決める だから決断っていうのは決めるっていうこと
一回で十分でしょうしね
どう見たってもね 毎日決断する必要ないんだからね
だから発心は一回で十分です
しかし 発心した菩薩もそれからずっとウッターナしなくちゃいけない
それを秒単位でやらなくちゃいけないんです
活発っていう でも日本語で別の意味で使いますから
活発はね いわゆる行動を起こす性格
精進なんで その場合 ヴィリヤという別な言葉あります
タイ語でサムエイガって言葉ありますよね
うん やっぱりこちらサムエイガもまた違います
これね 規律と書いてますよ
規律 紀元 奮起という言葉もあります
うん 奮起かな  気合を入れて
まあやっぱりそれ秒単位で必要かっていうね
だからまあ奮起ではいいとは思いますけどね
奮起っていうのはやっぱり秒単位で必要なんですね
まあネガティブな言葉ではね
めげないとかね 諦めないとかね
そういうふうには言う
なかなかしぶといとかね
また悪い意味で このなかなかこの許してくれない性格
この恨みはもう消してくれない性格って何て言いますか
何かありますね 言葉 少年部会とかね
悪い意味ではそんなもんなんですよ
いい意味では言葉ないっていうのはね
根気強いとか  まあ一応まあ奮起っていうふうな言葉を使いましょう
それでなんでこれが秒単位で必要かという
この難しい論理があります
それも理解してほしい
でないと仏教は勉強したことになりません
ただ軽々く何か覚えて覚えたってのを聞いたってもね
で これわかってもらえば誰でも成功しますよ
人生は みんな精神的に病気になるのはこの法律
法律じゃなくてこの法則わからないんだから
物事っていうのは一定していない
スーッと変わる 自分も変わる
世界も変わる 生きるということはその変わりの流れなんですね
だから自分がずっと変わって変わって変わっていく
変わって変わってる自分がずっと変わって変わってる世界と関係を持って生活しなきゃいけない
それは みんな無視するんです
無視することで法則そのものを無視するんです
変わらないと思っているんです
だから変わらないと思っちゃうと
結構がっかりすることやら失望することやらそっちゅうあるんです
だからこれ論理がものすごい難しい
難しいではなくて 納得するのは難しい
別に論理は簡単ですよ
論理だから方程式だから
自分というものは存在しない
ずっと変わっていくもので
で 自分が接している世界もずっと変わっている
瞬間でも同じもののリピートもない
だからそれが生きてるっていうことであって
それが法則であって それは事実なんです
ああ こんな事実 事実はこれだとわかったら
いかなる場合でもがっかりしたり
落ち込んだり 失望したりはしない
で この間来た子供を連れてきたお母さんでも
最初に私言ったのはもう子供は家族と一緒にいたくないと言ってるんだよと
だから自分がずっと言ってるんだよと
やっぱりみんな家族は仲良くした方が楽しいよと
仲良くしましょうと 子供は嫌やと言うんだと
一人生活したいと で 母親がもうかなり感情的で
もうそれにはえらいもう悲しい
どれほど感情的でよくもう喋るは喋るは喋るはまだ言ってない
言いたいことはね これは終わらないと思って
私は怒鳴ってもういい加減黙って聞きなさいと
私はこれから説明しますと
まだ本人が問題言ってないんです
そうするとまだ言いたい言いたいと
まあいいやと で それでもう
で それでもう一応喋る前にこちら知ってるんだけど
本人に言わせないともう感情が抑えませんだから一応言わせますけど
それでもこれいくら喋っても終わらないとね
もうこちらにももう我慢の限界ありますからね
まあいろいろ言って まあなんとかなんとかその問題は解決したと思いますけど
で 私はまあヒットポイントは全部変わりますよと
だからなんであのお母さんがものすごい感情的になって
悲しくなって もう泣きっぱなしで
もう自分のもうもうもう自信も全部粉々になくなってしまっちゃって
全くもう力も何もない状態になっちゃって
なんでそうなるかというと
この変わるんだっていうことはわかってないんです
それわかればね あ そんな年か
それだけでしょ すぐさっきまで甘えて甘えてたのに
だから子供はもう一緒にいたくない
もう独立してね ああ お前もそんな年になったんですねって
それ一言葉で済む問題なんですよ
ただそれだけで終わる問題です
その一言葉は出てこないんです
それですっごい問題 子供に向かって当たるでしょ
この両親が 聞いてみたら
お父さんがよく殴ったりするんだとこの子
もう行儀悪いわ いいことを聞かないわ
あれはいろいろあって
もうお父さん厳しくて
もうとんでもないことだと
で どう見たってもあなた二人よりはあの子の方が正しいと思いますよと
なんで間違い犯してるあなた方その子供を叱るんですかと
逆じゃないんですかと
そこでのんで親は嫌いになったんですかと
それさえ理解しない だから小さい時はお母さんが大好き
お父さん大好きと言うかもしれませんよ
しかし そのお父さんお母さん変わるでしょうに
どんどんどんどんどんどん話理解しないおばあさん
おじいさんになるでしょうに
だからその子供から見れば
もうもうバリバリの若者で
もう自分もいろんなことを知っていて
そういう話を通じない頑固なおばあさん
おじいさんの言葉聞いっていうのは当たり前でしょうに
そこでこの物事は変わるんだ
だからもうそこは一応あなたももうずっと変わってるんだと
あんたもう１０年前 もう前の人じゃないんだと
その人も変わるんだと
だからどちらでも変わるんだと思ったら
今の瞬間にどうすればいいということだけで問題は解決する
それで一応仏教の方でしょうし
まあもう別に本当に立派な家族ですけど
でお母さんがこう聞いたみたい
子供にでは家族を仲良くするためにどうすればいいんでしょうかと子供に聞いた
それもいい考え方なんですけど
で 子供はものすごい賢い答え出してあったし
でもそれやっても子供はまた断るっていうことで
それでも断ると なぜ断ると言っても
やっぱり子供が変化するんだから
この変化過程で自分の人生を設計したいんですよ
それで親の狙いは じゃあ子供はこういうことをやってくると
また前のように家族固めてギュウギュウと離れず一体型でいてくれるだろうと
それはありえない話ですからね
だからいろんなところであらゆる問題
我々はこのすべて変化するんだぞということはわからないんだから苦労しているんです
だから自分も変わるは世界も変わるは
それで今の私がいるのは今の瞬間だけ
もし今の瞬間すごくうまくいってるんだと
あ うまくいってるんだってすぐ怠けるんです
あ うまくいってる それですぐ思うんですよ
あ こういうふうにうまくいくんだよと
あれがえらい勘違いなんです
こういうふうにうまくいくわけじゃないんです
今うまくいっても物事は変化するんだから
だから我々は瞬間瞬間もう怠けたいってことをしちゃうんです
それがこの無常をわからないだからなんです
変化するっていうことをわからないだからなんです
例えば人がいい仕事してきた途端
我々はごく一般的に ああ
あんたすごい上手ですね
いい仕事をよくいい仕事をしてるんだのではないかというと褒めますけど
あれがすごい危険な褒め方なんですね
正しくはこの仕事は良かったと言った方がいいんですけど
嫌がりますね そういう風に言うと
私みたいな人だったらいつでも言うんだからね
嫌われる 嫌われる でもよくよく考えると
あのひとつ欠点をつけて言ってるでしょ
この仕事は完璧だと この仕事はと強調するでしょ
そうすると これは正しく
一般の社会ではそれはあり得ないことですけど
正しく見る人々 人だったら
やっぱり次の仕事も完璧になる約束ないってことをわかってるはずなんです
だから次の仕事にかかるときも
まあ完璧になるようにまた頑張らなくちゃいけないんです
いきなり私は褒めたら
あんたすごく立派な仕事をしますねと
完璧やと言うとダメなんですよ
この人はすぐもう腰を下ろすんですよ
上がるんじゃなくて できるんだよと
真理はそうじゃないんです
すべて変わるんです だから仏教は人に褒められても気にすんなよと
そんなのはもう全然あてにも何もならない感情だよと
賢者に褒められたらもうすごい
すごいです だから賢者に褒められるようにいなさいよと
賢者ってのはブッダのことなんですけど
ブッダが褒められる 褒められると
ブッダにそういうふうにちょっとした仕事をしただけで素晴らしいとは言わないんです
それは良かったというだけなんです
これが良かった 次のことは全然信頼してないんです
そこで人が無常がわかって無常の法則の中に生きてるんだったら
あなたのことは全く心配はないんだよと言うんです
あなたは間違いを犯すはずもないんだよと
その人は間違いを犯すはずがないんです
だからブッダに褒められたら
これこそ褒められたことなんです
そこら辺にいる人々が褒めても
みんなこの あの 一応褒めなきゃまずいというね
社会常識がありますから
褒めるために苦労して
なんとかほんのちょっとだけ見つけたらすごいすごいとね
大騒ぎで言うんですけど
あまり結果にはなりません
例えば子供の場合でもね
もう誰でもやってることでしょう
褒めるは褒めるは なんか落書きを描いて
あーすごい上手ですねとか言ったりするでしょうし
時々子供はそれを本気で取っちゃいますよ
それですごい失敗する
それから大人になる過程で
私も当然子供は褒めてほしいんだから褒めますけど
どこかでケチをつけておく
必ずつけておく 昔のいる方はいろんな絵を描いて見せてくれるんですね
子供にとってはもう全身力で描くんだから
まあ褒めなくてはいけないんですよ
もう一生懸命 まあ文字は書けないんだからね
なんとかなんとか描く
親やろうが 「ああすごい
いい絵ですね」とかなんとか言う
で 私に見せてくれる あ
絵描いたの？じゃあこれちょっと何でしょうかね
これ 説明してくれと 説明してもらうんです
あ なるほど そういうことかとかね
それで驚いたりびっくりしたり
そういうそれのことで褒めてないんだけど
この子供は褒められたという錯覚を起こすんです
あ なるほど そういうことかとかね
あ そういうこと こう書くんだとかね
それでその子供の知識能力は開発しますよ
いきなり「ああ いい絵だ
すごく上手ですね」とかね
これは無知な人のやり方で
だからこの そういう場合は全然問題ないんですよ
私のやり方でやると 決して貶したりすることはしませんし
で 逆にいい絵やいい絵だと言った言われるよりは
子供が一生懸命もうもう訳もわからない言葉で説明すると
説明をするんだけど それもこっちでわからないしね
もう子供の言葉だからね
まあ主語はないわ 動詞はないわ
あっちこっちが飛んだりするわ
それはいいんですよ 別に
とにかく本人は説明しましたから
それはまたその人にとっては大変プラスになるんです
ちゃんと絵を見てくれたという感じがするんです
[背景音楽]それ私は説明しながら
子供の脳細胞の構成やら
子供はこの子は何か表現するときはどういうふうなことで表現するかとか
それでこちらも逆に勉強しているんです
だからちゃんと子供の心理の世界はよくわかるんです
この子はこんな調子 この子はこんな調子やと
だからしつけする場合は
どういう単語をどういうふうに言えばいいかと
だから そのその子にそれぞれなりのバージョンで言うんです
同じことでも 昔ある子がいて
よく喧嘩する子供で 誰の話も聞かない
頭はすごく鋭かったんですけど
ものすごい喧嘩する ちょっとしたことでも感情を引き起こして
もう管理できない で あんまり誰とも仲良くしない
で 何か分からないんだけど
突然私と随分仲良くしちゃったんです
で まあ家はよく私は知ってる家で
まあかなり家はまあ立派な人々で
で 家の他のみんな随分親しくしていたんだから
まあ子供のことを無視するってこともできんし
それでその子はもうとにかく私の方に飛んできて
まあ親しくなったのはいいんだけど
あの性格 他の子供は私と喋ることさえ嫌がるんです
それは子供を殴ったってもいいんですけど
私にしてもこれ難しいんですね
他の子供も褒めてあげなくちゃいけないし
話してあげなくちゃいけないし
それで嫌な顔をするんだから
で それでまあもうじゃあ見てみるぞと
頭の中をね もうとにかくプライド高い
負けたくない ものすごい小さいんだけど
実はプライド高い だから子供だからそっちを負けたり
恥ずかしいことしたりするでしょうに
これで本人がもうかなり怒るんですね
自分がやったことであるか
ものすごい怒って他人に当たるんです
間違ったのはダメという感じで
性格はこの弟いたんです
その人はもう喋ろうともしない
あまりにもひどい状態で
完璧に喋れないのは子供は誰でもそんなもんでしょうに
何とか書いて欲しくて書いてくださいって言っても全然書かないんです
わかりまあまだまだ学校に行ってないんです
幼稚園なんだから書けないのは誰でも知ってるでしょうに
本人が自分が幼稚園でまだ文字書けないの知ってるんです
だから書きたくない それだったらいくつでも勉強できんでしょうに
直れないんですよ このすごいプライド
それで上の子にはもうある日私の前である
喧嘩したんですね 私の前では一応コントロールするんだけど
あまりにもコントロールできなくなっちゃって
もういきなり喧嘩しちゃったんです
私はこれヒストリーだからしょうがないんだから
まあそれでまあもうなんとかまあ終わるまで待っていて
一言葉君あれでかっこいいと思う
たったそれだけ あれでかっこいいと思ってるんですかと
会ったこと だから違っちゃいかんでしょ
ものすごいプライド高いんだから
それで私は随分信頼してるでしょう
それを壊してはいけないし
だから随分優しく仲がいいんだから
君あれでかっこいいと思うの？と
それっきりで直ったんです
それだけで 誰にも直すことできなかった問題
なんで簡単に直ったかと
やっぱり脳細胞の中はちゃんと理解しているんだからなんです
直っただけじゃないんですよ
それでまあまあ 学校でも友達がいっぱいいるわ
もう高校生になったところで
もういろんなところで友達いっぱい連れてきて
もうみんな立派な人 いい子たち
もう連れてきてくるんです
お寺にも私がいると消えちゃうと
みんな行儀が良くて もういい子だなと自分一人でも感心するんですよ
小さい子というのはすごい出家したいと言っていたんですね
あれは出家はもうみんなのこと嫌だから
私のところに飛び込んだ飛び込みがっているんだなということだから
私は何も返事出さなかったんです
で 私に大体あるといろんな計画持ってくるんです
で お坊さんはお母さんにこういうふうに言ってくださいと
それでお父さんが来たらこういうふうに言ってくださいと
それでおばさんの場合はまあまあこれでいいと
そうしちゃうと みんなまあ出家してもいいと言うんだよと
本人が計画立てるんです
親が反対だからね それは何のことね
親がいくら反対したっても
じゃあまあお寺にくださいと言ったらくれるんですよ
私はそれを言わない 親に
で そうするとあれほど忠誠心だからいいんじゃないかと一般的に思うでしょ
私はそう思わない で こんな性格だったらこれは逃げやと
私に甘えたいだけですよと
私はプライド傷つかないんだから
私とうまく生きるんだよと
この方が計画立ててるんです
しかし 出家はそんな甘くはないんです
こんなこんなにプライド壊されますからね
もう大変きつい世界なんです
だからこれがもうかなり頭痛の種になるんだぞということで遠慮していたんです
やっぱり高校生になったところで性格が変わって
もう本当に惜しいことをしちゃったなと
こんなに立派な子になるんだったらね
もらっておけばよかったなと
で まあそんなもんだから言いたかったのは
やっぱりこの一言葉で治ります
だから我々もこの物事は何でも変化するんだよということを理解しておけば
乗り越えられない問題っていうのは出てこないんですね
解決できない問題っていうのは出てこないんですよ
それであの私たちはみんなに何かレッテルの貼りたがるでしょ
レッテルは貼れないんですよ
それで打った穴は通って何なのかと
この奮起って何なのかというと
物事はもう我々は認めてももう認めなくても物事は変化する
自分が変わってない 変わってないだんだんそうとかなんとか
もういい加減なことを言っていても変わっている
認めない人はものすごい苦労する
前と全然変わってないんだそうというのも
あんまりにも嘘で何でも変わっている
なのにそれを理解しない人々は流れに流されるんですよ
だから流されていくいくことが成長向上じゃないんです
どうせ流されますからね
無常だから 別に変わ変わ変わ変えるために頑張らなくたっても変えます
変わりますからね だから工場がなくなっちゃうんですね
だからあまり人間っていうのは頑張らないんだから
ただまあ子供からどんどん大きくなって
まあ仕事を見つけて 結婚して
子供作って 年取って死ぬ
で 何のこともないんで
結局は何も残したことも何もない
それでも年 二 三年でもう子供は忘れちゃう
昔からも今もこれからも人間の人生っていうのはそんなもんだ
たとえ政治家になっていたてもすぐ忘れちゃう
ああ そういう人いたっけという感じになるんですよ
もう で あの流されてはいけないんですよ
で そこでいい方向へ変えるためには奮起しなくちゃいけないんです
瞬間瞬間 だから努力すること
励むこと 頑張ることはずっとないと瞬間瞬間ないとうまくいくわけじゃないんです
あの漬物論理ではできません
漬物をする まず一回だけでしょ
いろいろ合わせて漬けて置いておけば
まあそのまああのキムチとかね
まあ一年ぐらい置いておくんだからね
それで開けてみれば食べられるんだよと
放っておけば 我々人生にそう思ってるんです
一回何かやって放っておけばうまくいく
そううまくいくはずがないんです
ぬかみそはそういかないですよ
ぬか？味噌はね  日本の漬物はぬかみそっていうのがあるんですけど
それはそういかないんですよ
毎日かき回さないと  ぬかみそだったら毎日かき回さないと
まあキムチの場合はかき混ぜませんからね
漬けておくだけ しかし
このキムチを合わせて漬けたその秒から
もうその百済実体がね
ずっと変わっていくんですけどね
だから止まるっていうことはないんです
だから それはすごい厳密な論理で
この一切変化しているんだから
瞬間でも怠けちゃうと次は悪いんですよ
結果は流されちゃったんです
瞬間瞬間奮起すること
努力することには それにはこの瞬間瞬間奮起することなんです
ああ そうする自責できます
うん 難しいですよ 人間って怠け者だから
まあ難しいことは怠け者だから
つい怠けたくなると つい怠けたくなる
だから瞬間瞬間奮起しなくちゃいけないんです
ということは ウッターナワトという言葉は
まあそういう言葉で かなりこの単純な意味でもないんです
これは仏教の基本真理に基づいて言っている言葉なんです
これは次にある サティマドっていうのと意味が被っているような気配があります
被ってない サティっていうのはもう現在の状況にね
気づいていることだから
それは知恵につながるんですね
奮起するっていうのはただ立ち上がるだけのことだから
意欲を起こすみたいな
サティしてやろうっていう動機付けじゃないです
だからウッターナにも何もないんです
ただ立ち上がるだけの奮起するだけのことで
機能はサティなんですよ
料理作る気持ちと作ることは別々だからね
作りたい気持ちはすーっとなければできるんでしょ？作りたい気持ちだけでは何にもなりませんよ
作りたい気持ちはずっと 1 日中自責するんだと
何にもなりません だからウッターナがいいんだけど
何にウッターナですかと
何に奮起するかというとサティなんですね
だから結果はサティが出してくれるんです
まあ普通我々の世界でもね
よくあるんです 気持ちだけはあるんだけどね
まあちょっとごめん もうちょっとやめてくれませんか？というね
まあいくらでもあるでしょうね
本人はもう本当の本当に正直な気持ちでもうやりたくて
でもそれだけでは仕事にならんというね
ん まあ怠けっていうことはわかってないとは思いますけどね
あんた方は随分俗世間の次元で
そういう人々の価値観で聞いてるんですね
ブッダの価値観で聞いてください
そんなのは体休むことは悪いというのは俗世間でしょ
私は言ってないんです
ブッダも言ってないんです
休んではいけませんよとかね
そういう俗世間で金儲かることにしか値がない世間で
もうその価値観で瞑想する人もいっぱいいますけどね
まあそれでももうただもう何て言いますか
もう踏ん張って頑張ってみるっていうだけでね
私は褒めると思って 私は褒めない
私は結果で見るんだから
結果がなければ怠けてる
怠けてるんだよと ただずーっと夜も寝ないで頑張って食わないで頑張ってるんだよとか
バカじゃないかと 私はそれだけの反応で
私は今日は朝から食べてないんだよとかね
朝も食べてない 昼も食べてない
夜も大丈夫ですよと まあ瞑想してみますよと
どこら辺のバカやともう見てる感じ全然もうもう
慈悲も出てこないし 何かどうしてでもしてあげよう
褒めてあげよう ちょっと奨励してあげよう
そういう気持ちさえ出てこない
ああそう それはもうブッダの世界じゃないんだから
俗世間の考え方でね そんなもんで褒めてくれるかというようなんじゃないんですね
だから体が休んで それが怠け屋というのは誰です？私は言ったの
そんなこと うん でも世間ではそう言うかもしれませんでしょ
うん それは世間の考え方
夜仕事をしている人は朝寝ることは怠けですかね
そういうのはもう関係ないんです
怠けっていうのはものすごい微妙な世界なんです
怠けっていうのは無常に反対することなんです
例えば女性の方々よくやるでしょ
年を若く見せるためにいろいろもう塗ったり削ったり
筆でもう顔を描いたりとかね
あんなもん怠けなんです
いわゆる無常に逆らってみようっていうことです
先生 ボランターの妄想とかしているのは
うん それは怠けです まあ怠けは厳密にこの無常にもう逆らうことだけのことですね
まあだから怠け まあ全部
まあ全部ついてるの当たり前ですけど
一回死ぬんだから あれやこれやと聞くだけです
例えばお化粧の場合なんですけど
あの綺麗に見せるぞということで
別にそれ時点で悪くない
時々女の人の話聞いたことありますよ
で 男の人があんたすごく綺麗ですって言ったら
女ってのは化け物だよと
それあ この人はいいやと
その瞬間はそう思うんですよ
だから自分がかなり工夫してすごく綺麗に見せてるんだっていうことを本人がよく自覚しているんですよ
それに男が騙されたところで男をバカにするんですよ
女ってのは化け物だよと
そういう人々はそんなに精神的に落ち込んだりはしません
知った上でやってるんだから
でもほとんどの場合そうじゃなくて
本気で思っちゃうんだよ
自分がすごい年が若いんだと
無茶美しいやと それがもう怠けで
もう無常に逆らっていることで
かなり問題を起こすんです
そういう人々は 精神的には
別にもう歳になっても歳になってもね
すごく美しくお化粧してるのは
これは別の話で それは構いませんだけど
自分を騙しちゃいけないし
無常に逆らっはいけないしね
だからこの怠けっていうのは
この俗世間で思っていることとは違うんです
無常に従うことなんですよ
無常に従うことっていうのは結構難しいんだからね
無常という真理 事実を認める
その従う これが大変難しい
それをほっとくとが怠けであって
誰かにどうでもいい 何の意味もなく
どうでもない仕事を頼まれちゃって
もうやりたくはないと
それでサボっちゃう それは怠けじゃないんですよ
そんなのやったって何の意味もないよとかね
なんと言い訳しますよ
その時とかね 言って その時は実はね
こういう仕事もあって
これもあって これもあって
本当にもうできなかったんだよとかね
それがもう怠けじゃないんですよ
これはもうごまかしかもしれませんだけど
で やりたく怠けてやりたくない意味じゃないんで
その場合は ただ自分の考え方から見てやりたくないということでね
やらなくちゃいけないのに
やりたいのにやってない場合は怠けなんですね
まあ一応まあこの偈で
もう一つ大事なことをわかるんです
このアッパマーダという言葉っていうのは
仏教のキーワードで 全ての仏教は一つの言葉に入りますからね
ブッダの全部教えはアッパマーダという一言葉に入るんですね
だからこの大変な言葉で
それで日本訳される場合は不放逸とか訳されてますけど
それでも何やっとそれ？って意味わからないんだよね
不放逸って何なのかと
いろんな定義がアッパマーダにもありまして
こちらこの偈でもアッパマーダの定義が出てくるんです
で 奮起することをやる
怠けをなくして それからまあ常に気づいていること
まあ思うんですね 清らかな行為をちゃんと巧みに考えてやることと
決して悪い生活はしないことをやらね
で 落ち着いている 混乱しないようにずっと
これがアッパマーダなんですよ
このアッパマーダを実行すると確実に向上するんだよということなんです
向上はどんな定義でもいいんです
お金に定義したって その人は金儲かる
儲からないはずがないでしょうに
こういう生き方すると
知識で計算したっても
これぐらいの頑張る人は知識を得られないはずがないでしょうに
悟りで計算したっても
こういう風に頑張る人は悟らないはずがないでしょうに
だから何にも解釈できるように
その人の何でしたっけ？あの言葉
富貴 富貴名実というものがどんどん増えていくんだよと
その人は悟ります ちょっと意味が狭くなるしね
意味も狭くしないで こういうのは永遠の真理だよという立場でお釈迦様が語っているんだからね
これは何か在家の方に説法された時の
まあそんな話ですね 在家のある人の生き方について語ったもので
まあストーリーはそこら辺のテキストにもね
書いてると思いますけどね
原文ではあんまり長いんだからね
ストーリー自体は ある村でこの富豪の家庭がいて
家があって すごい金持ちなんです
しかし何か伝染病にかかったんです
で みんなそれで死ぬ 伝染病って何でしょうかと
こういうどういう病気がわからない
もうペスト可能性もありますけどね
インドはね まあ虫がいっぱいいるんだからね
あれでも人は死にますしね
それでまあ言われでは
その伝染病に家かかるとみんな死にますよと
しかし 家の壁を破って逃げたならば
逃げた人は助かりますという話で
村に入ると村はみんな死ぬ
まあどうせ伝染病だからね
まあ伝染病だったら逃げた人は助かりますからね
それは別にどうってことないんですけど
それでこの家がね もうすごいお金がある家で
それでこのやっぱり金銀はね
家で置いておくわけはないんだから
まあどこかでもう隠しておくんですね
で 昔のやり方はもう誰にもわからないどこかで埋めておく
埋めておくんです その場所は
その家の人々だけ知っているという
そこでこの親が病気になったところでこの子供がいて
子供に我々こういう病気にかかったんだから
みんなもう家でみんな死にますよと
だから君は我々のことをもう心配する必要もない
みんな死ぬんだからね
だから君はこの壁を破って逃げなさいと
しかし すべての財産はこういうところで
こういうところでまあ隠してありますから
いったん病気を治って
まあ消えて まあ元に戻って
まあ自分で生活しなさいと
いわゆる今風に言えば
まあ銀行の暗証番号を教えてくれたということで
で その人はまあみんなどうせ死ぬことで葬式なんかすることもできんしって
それで病気になるしね
だからまあ逃げたんですね
逃げたらもう自分の身寄りは誰もいない
自分の身分を証明してくれる人誰もいない
それでよく考えたんですよ
もうこれで私はもう病気治ったところで
あの財産を放り出して家を建てて生活しようかな
商売しようかなと思っちゃうと
私は逮捕されて殺されますよ
父様に 自当の金盗んだと
私はなんとかなんとか家の息子やってことにはもう今証拠ないんだからと
だから金があっても あれはどうでもいいや
自分に使えないんだと
ちょっとのお金じゃないんだから
これは億単位で金銀だからね
言ってまあ貧しいではなくて
自分の能力だけで生きてみますよということで逃げて
どこかでこの食器作る
あの素焼きのね そういう家に行って
まあそこで生活するんですね
見習い生活 まあストーリーはすごい複雑なストーリーですけどね
まあどんどん大きくなって
それでこのこの人はもう一つ仕事をしたんです
この朝起きてみんなを起こす仕事
その町の 結構力もあります
ですから朝早く起きてみんなに大きい声でもう朝だよ
起きてくださいということでね
あの日の出ような感じでね
その仕事もやっているんです
決して怠けない 威張ることをしない
私はあれやこれやとそれも言わない
誰何者ということでもなく
だからその皆らに入った家の奥さんもすっごく自分の子供のように
なんでいい子ですかという感じで
何の仕事も何も何文句言わずにやってくれるとかね
すごくみんなの愛情は帰るように生活していて
それである日 王様か誰かかな
そこら辺にいたところで
朝早くから声を聞いたんですね
王様は一応教育者だから
この声で占いますよ 占いいろいろありますからね
こういう占いもありますからね
朝早くなんかみんな起こす声を聞いた王様が聞いたところで
あれとびっくりしたんです
この声はもう大金持ちの億万長者の声だと
生まれつきすごい財産に恵まれているはずですよと
この人は しかし こういうもうすごい給料をもらわない単純な仕事でしょうね
そういう人っていうのは
こんな仕事するはずがないんだよ
と言って調べたところで
ああ もうあれ金持ちでも何でもないんだと
ただのもう親も誰も身寄りもない人だと
ただ粗悪作っているあの家で面倒見てくれてるだけですよと
でも王様が自分の占いはもう否定したくないんですよ
で 調べても調べてもまるっきり見つからない
この人にはお金あるっていうこと
その家の人々に聞いたなんて知ってるもんで
世の中金あるつくところだから
誰にもないんだと この人には
家でも何とかもうご飯食べていろいろ行動して
なんとかなんとかもうやってきてるだけですよと
で そんなはずがないんだと
聞いてくださいと その家の娘さんと
まあ一応気に入られて
まだ結婚してないんですけど
恋人同士みたいな感じなんですね
それで お母さん聞いても言ってくれない
お父さん聞いても全然私は貧しいんだよと
何もないんだよと言うだけで
で 娘さんの仲がいいんだから
お前聞いてみなさいと
言っても何？もうずっと一緒でわからないんですかと
こんなもんだよと 私はと
言ってくれない もうダメですと王様に言うと
王様それでめげないんですね
あれでもちょっとこれは信頼できないんだ
自分が勉強した占いは合わないのはちょっと納得いかないんだと
王様は自分の政治力を不正に使って
この村に命令するんです
みんな祭り一つしなさいと
各家から小判一つを出さなくちゃいけないんだと
祭りに出して祭りしなさいと
これ失礼な言い方なんですけど
これで計算したのは出なきゃすごい罰金やと
小判1000個罰金やと
言うと  1000個罰金するよりは 1個もう借金してでも払った方がいいんだからね
で 祭りになってきて この人々には小判一つもあるわけじゃないんです
そこで家がもう本気でびっくりして
これわからないんだから
計画っていうことがね
どうしようかと この工場やら全部売っても小判 1個にはなりませんと
その上どうやって罰金払いますかと
ものすごく悩んで困って
もうもうもう殺されるかもしれません
死刑になるかもしれません
困ってると もうだから女の子もこのいてどういうことだから
お父さん助けてよとかね
言って助けてって言ったって
どうやって助けるんですかと
もう家族みんなもうこれで終わりだよと
しょうがないよと って言うんですよ
言うんだけど やっぱり自分が育った家族だから
で このお金を出さなくちゃいけない日で
前の夜サーッと行って
自分の隠している財産から小判 1個持ってきて
じゃあこれあげてくださいと
家族を守るためにあげたんですね
それでこの小判に各家の判子を押してますからね
小判作る時でもね どんな家のお金かっていうね
別に今みたいに金そのものに価値があるんだから
別に誰の判子を押したってもいいわけでね
それでまあバレちゃって
それは王様に報告されて
どんな家のどれか どんな家どれどれ見たら
あの家からこれやとすぐわかるんだから
声がきれいな これとそれを王様持っていってその家を呼んで
これが誰が持ってきたんですかと
そしたらもうこのこの人もこれはこういう家の小判だよと
君にどうやってこれ手に入ったんですかと
言ったらまあ実はこういうことですと
自分の家の財産ですけど
自分のは使えないんだと
だから何のことなく潔く
こういう風に労働者の人生やってますよと
まあそれこそやっと素晴らしい生き方よと言って
王様が自分で全部お金を取り出して
彼はもう一度良心の位にまた豊かな人を通す億万長者として認定されたんです
それで娘さんと結婚したと
だからそこら辺でなんでこの人を使ってますかというと
やっぱり智慧がある人がきちんと頑張るんだという
バカなことはやりませんと
それでヤサっていうのは
だからだからヤサっていうことを使ってます
ゲダッスエラソートは使ってないんです
だからその人は名誉と財産と全部もらったんだからね
毎日しっかりと頑張って
お釈迦様は話には  お釈迦様のね
話には出てこない  これお釈迦様の時代の話だからね
ジャータカ物語だったらお釈迦様も出ますけどね
これはお釈迦様の時代でインドで起きた出来事で
それをちょっとエピソードとしてお釈迦様が使われた
だからその話をね お釈迦様の耳に入ってお坊さんたちからね
もうこの認定することを大げさな大変な祭りだからね
億万長者として 今までまずい人がね
話題になるでしょ それでお釈迦様はそういう人はこういう生活をしていたんだから
そんなように誰でもこれこれこれとこうなりますよというお釈迦様の話になっているんです
あまりこのエピソード
全部この偈には合わない場合たくさんありますからね
このダンマパダのエピソードっていうのは寄せ集めであるもので
別に合うことはない場合もあります
まあ彼もその説法を聞いたということはありますけどね
彼に対して教えたかな
そうですね 彼に説法したんだったという話ですね
ブッダに紹介した  ん？ 王はこの男を高官に昇進させ
ブッダに紹介した  うん
ブッダに紹介した  うん？ 王はこの男を宮官に昇進させ
じゃあ 時間はかなり来ましたので
先生 この偈は八正道に例えるんですか？入れ替えるっていうのは考えすぎでしょうか
例えばウッターナワトーは正精進に相当していて
サティワトーは正念に相当している
サチカンマッサは正業
ショーニャは正命 ニサンワカーリノーは正思惟
サンニャタッサは正定
ダンマジーヴィノーはダンマが正見でジーヴィが正命
八正道と  ダンマジーヴィノーはそのままで
正命  うん  [笑い]まあ別にね
考えて悪いわけじゃないんですけど
まあ八正道といえば八正道ですけどね
まあぴったし合ったり合わなかったりということもあるし
それはそんなに問題じゃないと思いますけどね
八正道の一つあっても八も入りますからね
八正道の場合は つなげてますからね
セットだから一つだけ取れないんです
だからこの中で まあおっしゃる通りに八正道に入れ替えることは不可能なわけじゃないんです
それでなんで八も出てこないんですかって言って困らなくてもいいんです
[笑い] 伝統的にやる場合は
それは注釈書ではやりますからね
これで八正道ですよと
まあいうことでね 注釈書ではやってないけど
まあ無理っていうことでもないんです
注釈書と私の違うところはあります
注釈書ではこのアッパマッタは別に定義するんです
で 私は別に定義しないで
偈を全部まとめて包囲する言葉に注釈したんです
そこで私は注釈書の訳と私の訳が違うんです
ブッダゴーサ長老はこの偈でアッパマーデの定義だよということは言わないんですね
アッパマーデは別に解釈する
ウッターナは別に解釈
別々バラバラに解釈する
私の解釈はウッターナから全部解釈してアッパマーデを解釈しない
それがアッパマーデですよと
それでカバーかけるんです
そこのポイントは違うんです
これは善行為をすれば必ず幸福になりますよということを示しているんですよね
まあ全部そうですけど
逆に言えば こういうことをすれば心配いりませんよと
うん まあ確実だよとね
まあ幸福っていうのはもう確定できますよ
だから無常の中でどう生きるべきかというね
無常の中で確立して確定保証があって生きていられる方法だから
それ以上は智慧がないんですよ
一切は無常ですからね
まあ無常だからしょうがないやということで
そういうことじゃなくて
その法律を発見 法律じゃなくて法則を発見して
それで確立した保証がある生き方をすると
仏教の日本 日本人が割と無常というとネガティブな感情として受け止める傾向が多いんですけど
仏教の無常っていうのはこういうふうにものすごくポジティブですよね
まあ無常はね ネガティブでもポジティブでもないでしょうにね
太陽は熱いということはネガティブ思考？ポジティブ思考？ まあでも
うん どっちでもどっちでもないんですけれども
日本人にとってみればネガティブに考えて仏教の教えは暗いよっていうふうに思う人が多いですけれども
こういうふうに示されれば
ポジティブがいいというわけではないですけど
みんなが好むことですよね
真理ですからね ネガティブポジティブという話じゃないんですよ
ネガティブポジティブというのは道徳的な価値判断の時でしょうしね
日本人は無常 日本人の話に乗る必要ないんですよ
日本人は仏教をわかっているんでしょうかと
日本人どころか誰の話も乗りませんだから仏教は真理わかってる人の話しか聞かんだから
まるっきりなんで目が見えない人から色の区別聞くんですかね
生まれたからも目が見えたことない人にちょっと色を選んでくださいとかね
これで綺麗と思いますか？とか誰が聞くんですかね
この絵の具でいいんですか？この色合わせがいいんですか？と目が見える人から聞くでしょうね
それも乱視じゃなくて
ちゃんとした色を認識できるね
人に聞くでしょうね だから何言ったって別に
まあ個人的に言ってくれると
それはもう直しますけどね
だから世の中わかるわかってないんだからね
真理はね 価値判断の世界じゃないんですね
真理の世界ではね 例えば夏は紫外線は多いんだよということは
ネガティブかポジティブかとかね
どちらでもないでしょう
紫外線は多いというぐらいのことで
自分が紫外線に当たりたくなければ気を付ければいいんですよ
なんて暗いネガティブ思考ですかと怒ったってもね
紫外線に当たってもう皮膚を黒くしたい人は
まあそれで紫外線に当たるでしょうし
もうそんな病気になるんだから嫌やと思う人はもう体を守ればいいということでね
しかし 事実を言ってもらわないと困る
あるいは今日はすごく紫外線のすごい激しい
しかし 政治的なことで
みんなどこかでもう外経済的にいろんなことがあって
もう今日は遊ぶためには大変いい日ですだよと
海水であろうか 旅であろうが何でもいいんだよと
どんどん言っちゃうと
これは良くないんですね
それでみんな外へ出て
あっちあそこはこっち行くわ
海水浴にみんな群がっちゃうわ
商売繁盛するかもしれませんだけど
みんな紫外線に当たって大変なことになる可能性ありますね
だから明るい思考やっていう風には言えない
それはもう裏切り行為ですよ
人の気持ちに沿って喋るっていうことは
だから商売に障りがあってもなくても
紫外線がたくさん出る
あるいは放射能が出るんだったら言わなくちゃいけない
近水が汚染しているんだったら
これ言わなくちゃ いけないんですよ
こんなこと言われるともう商売にならんぞとかね
やっぱり商売に関わりありますからね
やっぱり言わない隠しますよと
あの狂牛病の問題みたいでね
それが裏切りですよ 国民に
日本の牛肉は売れなくなっちゃって食べられなくて
みんな赤字になる 知ったことじゃないんですよ
で 狂牛病があるんだったら言わなくちゃいけない
前のケースも言ったのは全部骨まであちこち使ってから発表したんです
あまりにも残酷 裏切りなんです
まあ言わないで それはそのまま処分して黙ってたならばいくらか親切なんです
その牛を丸ごと全部処分して
そして黙って様子を見ていると
それ処分もしないで全部もうばらまいちゃって
それから言うという イギリスの場合も同じことでしょ
知ってるのに隠す なんとかの薬の薬作る会社の儲けのために
そういう人間もいる 信じられないんですよ
それほど人間裏切るかと
ただただ金のために だから事実っていうのはね
人の関係ある場合は隠してはいけないんです
まあそれは俗世間の話で
まあ仏教の場合はそういうことではなくて
まあもっとそういうのはね
普遍的な真理の世界ですからね
無常っていうのはネガティブでもポジティブというわけでもなく
太陽は結局熱いんだよとかっていうふうなことで
あまりにも暑くて嫌だな
普段となくあったよと
こちら知ったことじゃないんだよと
ではちょっと時間過ぎておりますので
これでおわりにしたいと思います
それでは最後に参拝して終わりたいと思います
参拝